well I guess everybody was in love with
Marine O'Hara in the early 50s I was a
contract player at Universal Pictures I
was getting 75 a week and by the time
was 40 weeks a year by the time I was
prorated out I'd bring in 60s was great
I could get a few beers that's about all
but anyway I wasn't having great luck I
was doing maybe a line here and a line
there at a picture and finally down the
front office they said we got this
picture called Lady Godiva of Coventry
and I thought oh yeah I remember that
that's what that's really réguel
protests and a town and all that sort of
thing yeah I know and we got Marine
O'Hara well this was the first movie
star on that I've met some other movie
stars but they weren't really what we
started this was really his movies and I
said you know hair I say then I'm gonna
be in there I'll be there reading
reading one line and I'll just hang out
because she's supposed to be naked on
this horse I'm thinking my fantasies are
going really well with this particular
plane so I thought well I'll just kind
of hang out and maybe I can help out so
I I saw some people productions people
over to one side and I went it i saddled
up over there like cuz I saw Miss O'Hara
she came out in a bathrobe she's sitting
there and I'm going my I'm going this
has got to be really great I'm in the
scene and so anyway they assistant
director comes over and says hey kid
move out of the way we have please stand
I said well you know if she needs us
lift off the horse or something like
that she could use my head or anything
you know she couldn't stick her foot in
my mouth I don't care I'm not a fetish
person but I mean she's the most
beautiful woman in the world
so I thought this is this is fantastic
so anyway we did the picture and that
was it and I went on and did hundred
other bits have never got anything but I
never forgot her never forgot that face
she's the ultimate Irish lass and it was
I I would love to be the guy who dragged
her across the countryside and got her
to the church but that was the Dookie
and he was that was his era so I'll have
to find some younger girl and I'll be an
older guy doing it but anyway so I like
to bring her out now